Да,
[Música]
சரணமி
சங்க
சரன
[Música]
பிบ
সнan
[Música]
சரமி
சனமி
[Música]
비บ
সнчами
[Música]
Pam
saran
[Música]
비상
Saran
[Música]
Namat
sam사
[Música]
Sex
guru
[Música]
아마도
Candr
[Música]
sexo sma
honra rom.
Gurup
honra benzor gurup
de honra romz
gurup
de rom hon rom
gup
honra romz
gurup
de rom hon romar
gur
[Música]
Gurup
honrá
[Música]
honra romar
gurup
honra romzara
honra benzara gurup
de
[Música]
para
tempте
[Música]
Paraga
para sangте
[Música]
paraгате
Bra
[Música]
para semb
Paranga
[Música]
tempanga
de sate
[Música]
para
teu band de
[Música]
para
tempanga
[Música]
de sra.
Agora nós vamos pra página 20.
através de homenagens, oferendas,
confissão, regozijo, solicitação e
súplica. Qualquer pequeno mérito que eu
tenha gerado, dedico a que todos possam
alcançar a iluminação.
A terra está ungida com água perfumada,
espargida de flores e adornada pelo
Sumero, os quatro continentes, o sol e a
lua. Por eu ter imaginado e oferecido
isso como um reino búdico, possam todos
os seres usufruir dos reinos puros. A
terra está ungida com água perfumada,
espargida de flores e adornada pelo
Sumeros, quatro continentes, sola, por
eu ter imaginado e oferecido isso como
um reino búdico, possam todos os seres
usufruir dos reinos puros. A terra está
ungida com água perfumada, ungida de
flores e adornada pelos sumeros, quatro
continentes, o sol e a lua. Por eu ter
imaginado e oferecido isso como um reino
búdico, possam todos os seres usufruir
dos reinos puros.
Ratna mandala.
Para satisfazer a necessidade de todos
os seres em seus diversos níveis de
compreensão, solicitamos a você que gire
a roda do dharma, incluindo as
abordagens menores e maiores, comuns e
extraordinárias.
através desse mérito, que todos os seres
possam se tornar oniscientes e alcançar
o estado búdico, derrotando todas as
faltas e impedimentos. Que todos os
seres possam ser liberados do oceano da
existência condicionada,
agitada pelas ondas do nascimento, da
velice, da doença e da morte.
Bom dia.
Então, surgiu uma dúvida que eu vi uma
conversa aqui online que nós estamos sem
energia elétrica, né, de fato, mas a
gente tá desde o início da semana sem
energia elétrica aqui da rede, né? Mas a
gente tá sobrevivendo. Parte com com a
energia solar e parte com o banco de de
baterias aqui. Tá tá funcionando.
Às vezes tem uma outra flutuação e tem
que alterar o sistema, mas hoje o Maca
chegou no ponto do melhor.
Maca sempre ajustando aqui, arrumando as
coisas.
Então, tá tudo funcionando.
A gente não deve comemorar porque nós
estamos com esse problema. Comemorou,
vai dar problema.
Mas nós estamos indo.
Então aí nós vamos seguindo. Eu queria
falar assim de modo geral, né, de modo
assim comentário, né,
que é sobre o que que nós estamos de
fato fazendo com esse com esses
eh com essas instruções de Satipatana,
né?
Então, o que acontece é que nós estamos
fazendo prática dos bicos. Os bicos, num
certo sentido, são aqueles que tomaram
refúgio no Buda, no Dar, na sanga, né?
Eles entram na corrente. Então, eu acho
muito apropriado que a gente olhe essa
oferenda de mandala, examine isso, né?
Porque é essencialmente isso que
significa
a gente de fato tá praticando, né?
Porque nós agora nós não estamos
olhando, bom, nós estamos em países, em
regiões e nós somos profissionais disso,
daquilo. Nós não estamos olhando isso,
né? Nós estamos olhando num sentido
muito mais amplo, né? Ou seja, nós
estamos numa terra pura onde a lucidez
pode surgir.
E esse é o ponto. Esse é o ponto, né? E
a gente espera que todos os seres possam
acordar e surgir nos reinos puros e que
eles eh eles possam revelar a sua
própria natureza, né? Então essa é a
base de compreensão. A gente tá nesse
lugar, esse é o ponto, né? Aí a prática
que nós fazemos é assim, é
essencialmente a prática do dharma. Isso
que é a prática do dharma. Isso é o
retiro. Isso. Eu não sei porque que a
gente chama de retiro, porque isso
deveria ser a nossa prática usual,
mas tá certo que a gente
por vezes
tem a sensação de que é necessário um
retiro, que a gente se afasta das
demandas que são feitas sobre as
identidades que a gente que a gente
exerce né?
E enquanto nós estamos exercendo essas
identidades, nós estamos exercendo as
identidades, ou seja, as inteligências
correspondentes.
E nesse caso, essas identidades elas
elas vão ter muitos problemas, né?
E ainda que a gente tenha uma liberação,
a gente sabe como é que é essa
liberação, porque essa é a nossa
experiência, né? Uma vez que a gente
atua com uma identidade, daqui a pouco
te deixa ela guardada e parte para outra
e começa a funcionar de um outro jeito.
Então, quando a gente tá, por exemplo,
operando com uma identidade, tipo, uma
identidade familiar com o pai e mãe, as
frustrações que a gente tem, os
sofrimentos que a gente tem, não dizem
respeito a outras identidades, porque a
gente não tá exercendo as outras, mas
vamos sofrer por quê, né? Mas aí a
pessoa se esquece disso e começa a
assistir um jogo de futebol. Aí ela
pessoa, ela não tá mais com sofrimento
da identidade de pai e mãe, mas tá com
sofrimento do resultado do jogo. É
assim, aí a pessoa se transfere para pra
identidade de trabalho, assim, domingo
de tarde a pessoa, pá, amanhã eu tenho
que trabalhar. Uau, eu não apresentei
tal coisa. Aí, pronto, aí tem um um
estresse correspondente
a essa outra identidade. Mas e e as
anteriores? Anteriores a gente liberou.
Aham. Levan ela ficou ficou guardadinha,
pronta, com uma estrutura cármica
prontinha para eu mergulhar dentro e
girar de novo, né? Então essa é a nossa
situação. A gente não tem nenhuma, como
é que eu vou dizer, nenhuma situação
nova. É isso. Desde sempre.
Parte dessas identidades que a gente
mergulha, nós mesmos geramos, outras a
gente herda. A gente recebe a
transmissão,
né? Com no primeiro dia de trabalho, a
pessoa entra lá, vai receber a transição
da identidade do sofrimento nos próximos
35 anos, se a pessoa seguir ali, né? É
assim, aí pessoal aqui é isso, agora
você faz isso e tal coisa lá e tal outra
coisa ali, o banheiro é aqui, o café
ali, pessoal, ah, tá tudo bem. A pessoa
tá achando que chegou no lugar amplo,
mas a pessoa chegou na prisão, banheiro
é ali, aquilo é ali. É assim, ela a
pessoa vai ficar presa naquele ambiente
por um longo tempo. Mas que pessoa?
Aquela identidade, quando ela sai dali,
chega em casa, tem outra identidade
esperando, é outra prisão, é um outro
tipo de prisão e aquilo segue. E aqui
nós escolhemos um tipo especial de
prisão, que seria assim, o retiro.
Retiro é assim, eu tô livre das outras
prisões, só tenho essa agora.
Sim, mas essa aqui é uma prisão
especial, é uma prisão numa terra pura.
O que a gente faz aqui é escapar das
prisões. Na verdade aqui é uma antessala
da liberação, pessoal. É assim, a gente
abandona as outras porque por esse modo
tão simples assim. Aí eu saí, pronto, aí
minha mente tá aqui. De modo geral, as
pessoas vêm com a mente para cá. Nem
sempre, né? Às vezes elas seguem em
algum outro lugar, elas estão só de
corpo aqui né?
Mas aí nós estamos aqui.
E aqui o que que a gente faz aqui? Nós
somos bicos.
Isso é bonito. Cada um tinha que ser um
nome, tem que ter um nome. Bico mel,
bicini,
assim, aquilo era bonito assim, fazer
uma coisa assim, né? E o que que os
bicos fazem? Os bicos, pum, eles estão
ali olhando. Uau, eu respondi
condicionado.
A energia mexeu e aquilo foi. E agora o
outro tá falando: "Eu tô entendendo
tudo. Que horrível. Isso é tudo
condicionamento.
E aí nós estamos olhando todas as
estruturas de resposta automática. Nós
estamos desenraizando isso da forma mais
profunda. E aqui nós vamos usar mente e
o corpo. Podia falar corpo, fala e
mente,
mas a fala tá dentro do corpo, tá dentro
da mente. Então tudo bem. O Buda vai
falar de corpo e mente,
mas nós vamos purificar corpo fala e
mente. Purificar significa o quê?
Reconhecer o aspecto vágera,
o aspecto não dual, luminoso, vazio,
né? inseparável da própria mente, de
cada experiência que a gente tiver
fazendo. É assim, se a gente tá fazendo
isso, pessoal, isso é o que as pessoas
fazem, como tão quando tomam refúgio.
Toma refúgio é isso, toma refúgio no
Buda, natureza lúcida, toma refúgio no
Dharma, que é o software de ficar
olhando para aquilo que prende e vendo.
Então vocês já vão olhando assim, nós
estamos procurando aquilo que nos
prende,
né? Por isso que é super importante as
pessoas disruptoras,
né? Agora a gente tinha uma pessoa
disruptora aqui, agora já não tem mais.
Eh, assim, mas eh esse é essa é a função
daquilo que a gente chama de daquines,
né? Daquines, elas são, se vocês olharem
na na
a palavra daquine, assim, na na tradição
védica, aquilo não é nada nobre assim,
pessoal.
daquines significa um comportamento não
previsível,
não
causal,
que simplesmente faz as coisas
acontecerem,
mas eh nos conecta diretamente no karma.
Nosso karma
aparece.
Aí nós estamos olhando os karmas, aquilo
tá bem.
Quem tem coragem reza para que os caras
apareçam, né? Assim, quem não tem
coragem é melhor não rezar,
porque eventualmente os carmas aparecem,
né? De rea os carmas aparecem. Que que
significa isso? Aí as coisas aparecem
diante de nós, nós respondemos
automaticamente.
Mas se eu não tiver uma capacidade de
transformar aquilo em prática, aí
é melhor a gente aí aquilo surge como
elefantes furiosos, como eh serpentes
venenosas, aranhas e animais pessoas
variados, que o Buda diz: "É melhor
fugir."
Mas se nós olhamos como se nós temos a
capacidade de olhar para aquilo e ah
reconhecer como que nós somos
enganchados, como que a nossa mente
começa a operar por gostar ou não gostar
e começa a gerar originação dependente.
E nós temos a capacidade então de
reconhecer esses gatilhos todos que são
estruturas cármicas. Aí nós começamos a
purificar todas as aparências que surgem
e os próprios gatilhos, né? Eh,
purificar os gatilhos significa repousar
na natureza livre, que reconhece todas
as manifestações como luminosidade,
vacuidade, não doais com a mente, né?
Então isso é o trabalho dos bicos.
por favor.
>> Usando esse exemplo do futebol que o
senhor tem meio atrás,
>> ã, por exemplo,
>> quinta-feira eu tava assistindo da noite
Flamengo e Galo. Não tava na minha
identidade de torcedora, porque eu não
torço para nenhum dos dois. Então eu fui
capaz de comemorar um gol que achei
bonito.
>> Foi o jogo
>> Flamengo e Galo. E
>> e como é que foi? Me conta.
>> Se é isso que eu ia lhe dizer
>> para ver como eu não tava vestida na
minha identidade de torcedor, eu
levantei depois e fui dormir e não sei
nem qual foi o resultado do sabe
resultado.
>> Mas enquanto eu tava assistindo, eu
comemorei um gol bonito, xinguei o juiz,
enfim.
>> Mas gol de quem?
daquele do
>> Eu tô ficando nervoso agora.
>> Aquele jog
>> tem mais gente aqui que tava agora
>> aquele jogador que ficou famoso no na
Copa das Seleções que ele todo mundo
dizia chuta, Everaldo. O Everaldo fez
dois gols bonitos.
>> Tu sabe de que time é o Everaldo?
Somos de um consultor urgente aqui,
porque assunto tem que se clarificar.
Mas aí eu fui dormir, não vi o resultado
do jogo, então eu não tava vestindo a
minha identidade de torcedora.
Se fosse meu time ia ser diferente. Mas
aí eu fiquei, mas eu me dei conta disso.
Quando eu subi para dormir, eu disse:
"Ah, nem vou ver o resultado do jogo,
nem vou me importar com isso".
E e mas tem assim coisas que eu não
consigo, que não estão relacionadas
comigo
diretamente, como violências com
crianças e mulheres, por exemplo, que
não interessa se eu conheço ou não
conheço, se tá longe ou se tá perto, eu
fico totalmente engatilhada, totalmente
presa naquela identidade de sofrer com
aquilo.
que eh algumas coisas são mais fáceis da
gente se livrar da identidade. Claro, eu
tô usando dois exemplos meio ruins, né?
porque é futebol e sofrimento, mas
enfim, eh, induída na identidade
torcedora, às vezes a gente não consegue
se livrar de um sofrimento bobo, né, de
perder um jogo. E e numa identidade de
de olhando a violência contra outras
pessoas muito distantes, eu fico
totalmente engajada e visto uma
identidade muito forte. Essas essa agora
o senhor falou em karma, isso significa
provavelmente algum karma meu para me
conectar diretamente com com aquilo que
me faz sofrer mais?
>> É de fato. Agora, nesse contexto aqui da
nossa prática, a gente tá tomando por
base a mente livre de características.
Eu não tô tomando uma mente que tá
postulando justiça, por exemplo.
Eu não tenho um critério sobre o que que
deveria acontecer no mundo e vejo que
aquilo não tá andando direito. Esse não
é o ponto. Tô com a mente aberta
e aí eu vejo surgirem eh
daria para dizer que grosseiramente
quando eu não tô na identidade ali
olhando um jogo que não me interessa e
que eu sou capaz de
só torcer ou só achar bonito o jogo ou
só achar bonito o gol e não me envolver
com aquilo, eu tô com uma mente mais
livre. seria uma analógia,
>> livre de algumas coisas, mas como tu tá
atento ao jogo,
>> então o jogo ele tá, aquelas luzes estão
produzindo significados para ti. Então
esse fato de que as luzes produzem
significado já é observado também como
um movimento da mente que ela tá criando
significado porque tem aqueles pixels
todos, mas tu tá vendo jogadores, tu tá
vendo o campo e tá vendo um uma bolha de
realidade, tá entendendo aquilo. Então
isso já significa que tu pode contemplar
como que a gente surge em mundos de um
certo tipo.
Nesse caso, como aquilo vem por uma
tela, é é mais especial, porque quando
tu olha para aquilo, tu vê que tu não
tava vendo o campo, tá vendo um monte de
pixels e tu tem um um significado que
brota amplo na tua mente assim, ligado
àqueles aquilo que tu começa a ver
assim, né? Então surge um mundo de
características né?
Então, nós estamos olhando isso
aí. Há variados grupos de experiências
que nos aguardam. De modo geral, as
experiências mais importantes, melhores,
se a gente consegue, né, são as
experiências que nós temos conexão
cármica.
Então, às vezes, essas experiências elas
são tão densas, importantes, que a gente
não consegue trabalhar dentro de um de
uma prática como essa nossa aqui. Então,
a nossa prática é uma prática super
corajosa,
é uma prática direta. Nós estamos
expostos olhando isso assim. caminho
direto.
Mas, por exemplo, para aqueles que não
estão conseguindo seguir por aí, eles
podem seguir o conselho do Buda, de
evitar certas áreas, porque essas áreas
são perturbadoras, então nós não
conseguimos lidar com aquilo. A gente é
simplesmente arrastado,
então a gente não consegue.
Por outro lado, dentro do vajorena, tu
vai, a gente vai tomar uma dessas mentes
cármicas, ela termina virando uma
deidade. Eu vou dar um nome de deidade
para ela começa a trabalhar. E o grande
mérito dessa deidade é o fato de que eu
tendo, por exemplo, medos,
então eu não preciso me preocupar em
concentrar a mente no medo, porque eu já
tenho medo. só evoco as situações
e eu já não me distraio porque eu fico
focado naquilo. Aí nós fazemos a
prática, aí surgem muitas diferentes
deidades, né? assim.
Então, a prática, por exemplo, a prática
a prática do praj na paramita, ela pode
surgir desse modo,
né? Eu posso evocar os medos e lidar com
a vacuidade diretamente dentro daquilo,
né? Então, tem as práticas mais
variadas.
Como nós temos desejos e apegos, nós
temos aspiração por por recursos também
a gente pode fazer práticas e aquilo
também nos concentra. Eu digo: "Não, eu
quero isso." Aí surge uma deidade que
oferece isso.
Essas deidades todas elas são vazias.
Se vocês virarem devotos das deidades,
vocês vão praticar por pelo menos umas
sete vidas para poder se livrar disso,
porque nós precisamos reconhecer que as
deidades são vazias e esse é o controle
de qualidade. Mas tudo bem, isso é uma
uma maravilha que tu possa focar a
mente, seguir praticando como se aquilo
fosse tudo muito verdadeiro, que tu
tem uma conexão daquela deidade com o
obter os resultados correspondentes.
Esse aspecto, na verdade, é tá
transformando o próprio o próprio mara
em caminho. A gente olha pra Mara e vai
transformar em caminho.
Então eu acho importante a gente
entender qual é a prática. Hum. Então
vocês vejam, esse tipo de prática não
vai dizer primeiro ponha a perna
esquerda sobre a perna direita, o pé
esquerdo sobre a perna direita, o pé
direito sobre a perna esquerda. sente
reto e faça isso, aquilo. Não, isso aqui
é uma instrução de lucidez.
Essa instrução de lucidez, ela é
meditação e ela é também a instrução que
segue no período pós-meditação.
Então, esse é o nosso, essa é a nossa
prática. Nós estamos aqui para praticar
isso.
E algumas vezes, ou muitas vezes, a
pessoa pensa: "Bom, mas então eu faço o
que agora?
É assim,
aí quando a pessoa perguntar isso aí a
pessoa pode ler um trecho, ler todo o
satipatana que tá cheio de sugestões
aqui das coisas que nos engancham, nos
atrapalham.
E aí nós tomamos aquilo e passamos a fé,
né?
Então agora, ontem nós concluímos a
parte do corpo, agora nós vamos entrar
na parte da mente, né?
Eu
Não. E como bicos? Umbico permanece
contemplando a mente como mente. Aqui
umbico compreende a mente afetada pelo
desejo
com a mente afetada pelo desejo. E a
mente não afetada pelo desejo, como
mente não afetada pelo desejo.
Então nós vemos características em tudo
isso, né? Aí nós estamos assim, a gente
pode dizer: "Uau, minha mente não foi
afetada. Minha mente foi afetada".
Mas a prática de fato
de fato é
a a aquilo que vai aparecer lá como
insight, como visão,
que é o fato de que enquanto a pessoa
olha a olha as aparências como estados
que surgem,
a pessoa se mantém independente. Então,
progressivamente surge uma familiaridade
com essa independência. Esse aspecto
independente é a própria mente do Buda e
guru yoga,
né, que é, enfim, a confiança
no prágio na paramita, a confiança na
lucidez que brota dessa natureza livre e
ampla.
Então, nós estamos olhando muitas
categorias de surgimentos sutis da mente
apenas para reconhecer que aquilo é
construído.
Eu não tô avaliando se aquilo é bom ou
não é. Eu tô apenas vendo aquilo como
uma construção.
Então aqui umbico compreende a mente
afetada pelo desejo com a mente afetada
pelo desejo e a mente não afetada pelo
desejo com a mente não afetada pelo
desejo.
A gente podia pensar, bom, mas ele é um
monge?
Como é que ele tem a mente afetada pelo
desejo?
Sim. Mas aqui nós estamos fazendo uma
outra prática. A samaia
é a lucidez, não é que certos estados
não apareçam e outros estados apareçam.
Não é isso? é a lucidez frente a
qualquer tremor, qualquer movimento da
mente.
Então aqui um bico compreende a mente
afetada pelo desejo como a mente afetada
pelo desejo e a mente não afetada pelo
desejo como a mente não afetada pelo
desejo.
Então, como é que ele pode
ele pode verificar,
compreender a mente afetada pelo desejo
se ele não tiver o desejo?
É assim. Então aqui o Buda já tá
introduzindo desejo como caminho
e também a mente não afetada pelo desejo
com a mente não afetada pelo desejo. Ele
compreende a mente afetada pela raiva
com a mente afetada pela raiva. Então
todos esses aspectos perturbadores, eles
se transforma em caminho.
E a mente não afetada pela raiva, como a
mente não afetada pela raiva. Ele
compreende a mente afetada pela delusão,
que é essencialmente as oito consensas,
né?
como a mente afetada pela delusão. E a
mente não afetada pela delusão, como a
mente não afetada pela delusão.
Ele compreende a mente contraída
como mente contraída e a mente distraída
como mente distraída.
Ele compreende a mente transcendente
como mente transcendente e a mente não
transcendente como mente não
transcendente.
Ele compreende a mente superável como
mente superável e a mente não superável
como mente não superável.
Então aqui todos esses termos eles foram
traduzidos paraa língua portuguesa. Para
nós isso não faz muito sentido, mas as
palavras em sânscrit elas têm um sentido
exato
que se referem a estados do mundo da
forma e da não forma. Que ele tá usando
essas palavras aqui.
Ele compreende a mente concentrada como
mente concentrada e a mente não
concentrada como mente não concentrada.
E ele compreende a mente liberada como
mente liberada e a mente não liberada
como mente não liberada.
Então é isso aí. Vocês podem olhar esses
vários conteúdos como essencialmente
a mente do mundo do desejo, mundo da
forma, mundo da não forma.
Dessa forma, qual é a prática mesmo?
Dessa forma, ele permanece contemplando
a mente como mente internamente. Então,
ele vê a mente de todos os lados,
com permanece contemplando a mente
comumente externamente ou permanece
contemplando a mente como mente tanto
interna quanto externamente.
Ou então ele permanece contemplando os
fenômenos que surgem na mente e ele
permanece contemplando os fenômenos que
desaparecem na mente
ou ele permanece contemplando ambos os
fenômenos que surgem,
>> assim como os fenômenos que desaparecem
na mente. Que esses dias estavam
pensando em ti, menina. Cadê esse povo
que ninguém? inção plena de que existe a
meda viajando a
>> se estabelece somente na medida
necessária para o conhecimento, para
continuidade da atenção.
>> Pois é, eu só sou da Luci porque eu tava
viajando, eu não fui porque eu tava
viajando.
>> O resultado, porque ele tá vendo essa
essas mentes su
>> e essas mentes cessam,
>> tá? Tá todo mundo cessam. Não, você tem
13 anos que eu moro aqui perto do salão.
>> Desenvolve essa visão. Ele vê que aquilo
que nós vamos chamar de mente
é algo que surge tá vendo que tem
promoção aqui para olhar a promoção
>> é o único que ainda três que não fechou,
né? Ele conclui
>> que essa noção de que existe uma mente
que então eu tô contemplando, eu tô
contemplando
configurações que surgem delusivamente
excessam
e portanto eu não eu não posso afirmar
de um modo verdadeiro a existência de
uma mente, uma vez que tudo aquilo que
que me traz a sensação de existência da
mente é algo que surge e cessa.
E portanto
eu vou usar essas palavras
apenas na medida necessária para o
conhecimento e para a continuidade
da atenção plena. Então eu tô
contemplando esses aspectos e usando
essas palavras nesse sentido, mas eu não
consigo dar um uma realidade de
existência permanente, de existência
verdadeira.
Tá? Então isso é como que uma ah
uma
vacuidade com respeito à própria mente,
né?
E aí vem o resultado. E ele permanece
independente, sem nenhum apego a
qualquer coisa mundana. Então ele tá
olhando isso, ele permanece
independente, sem nenhum apego a
qualquer coisa que
>> surja e cesse as coisas
>> duais,
aparentes.
Assim é como um bico permanece
contemplando a mente. Comumente
>> onde eu pego café ali. Aí eu já pago
ali.
>> Então esse é o ponto. Então nós estamos
fazendo a mesma prática sempre. Tá bom.
OK. Obrigada.
>> Agora nós passamos pros objetos mentais.
Então vocês vejam, pessoal, é sempre a
mesma forma de praticar. Eu só tô
procurando
as flutuações da mente, eu nomeio elas
com pequeno mesmo, tá?
na estabilidade, na na grande abertura
em Chamatã,
eu procuro o que faz, o que produz um
tremor. Aí eu dou nome para esses
tremores internos e sequências de
originação dependente.
É como se a gente tivesse nomeando,
vasculhando os demônios, interferências
fantasmagóricas, espíritos despeitados e
malévolos e marcando um X naquilo.
Aquilo não é. Então, nós estamos fazendo
um contraste, nós estamos fazendo uma
leitura das aparências
diretamente
desde um pano de fundo vazio.
Nós não estamos, por exemplo,
olhando a partir de um conjunto de
aspectos que a gente poderia considerar
positivos, né? Então, emoções positivas,
motivações positivas. Eu não tô olhando
isso. Eu tô olhando simplesmente
o que tá presente ou não tá presente.
E isso é definido desse modo. Ele
permanece independente, sem nenhum apego
a qualquer coisa mundana. Assim é como
um bico permanece contemplando a mente
como mente.
E agora vem os objetos mentais.
Então ele vai ele vai mergulhar nos
conteúdos dessas múltiplas mentes que
vão aparecendo.
Não há objetos mentais que não sejam os
próprios
os próprios
a própria manifestação luminosa.
Os objetos mentais eles não se separam
da própria mente, né? E como bicos, um
bico permanece contemplando os objetos
mentais como objetos mentais.
Aqui um bico permanece contemplando os
objetos mentais como objetos mentais
referentes aos cinco obstáculos.
E como um bico permanece contemplando os
objetos mentais como objetos mentais
referentes aos cinco obstáculos.
Então,
esses obstáculos eles estão relacionados
como desejo sexual,
má vontade,
desinteresse e perda de foco, torpor e
sonolência,
agitação e ansiedade e dúvida.
Aqui eles descrevem desejo sexual.
Eu acho que a tradição deveria ser
desejo sensual.
Então eu vou ler desse modo, né?
Então em outras partes, em outros
textos, eu pesquisei isso,
né? Tá apontado desse modo, né? Aqui nós
vamos olhar como desejo sensual, porque
é uma forma, é o mundo do desejo,
o desejo sexual muito, muito estreito,
né?
Sensual, né? É isso.
Mas os cinco obstáculos em outros
lugares, eles estão descritos como
desejo sexual.
O desejo sensual, o que que é? Mundo do
desejo. Tem olhos, ouvidos, nariz,
língua e tato. Tem desejos em todas as
direções. Como é que isso se movimenta?
É fácil de ver porque não importa o que
a gente olhe, ah, nós temos uma conexão
do mundo do desejo. Então, no nosso
próprio corpo surge um movimento de
energia,
um movimento luminoso, surgem sequências
de originação dependente.
É simples.
Nós temos uma clareza de que as
aparências interferem nossos estados
mentais.
Nós usamos as aparências de olhos,
ouvidos, nariz, lengua e tato como
ancoragem por os estados mentais. Por
isso que nós reclamamos dos outros,
reclamamos do ambiente, reclamamos de
várias coisas como perturbadoras aos
nossos estados mentais, porque nós
estamos dentro do mundo do desejo
sensual.
Nós temos essa ligação. O desejo sensual
significa que eu uso objetos de olhos,
ouvidos, nariz, língua e tato para
estabilizar estados mentais que eu não
tô conseguindo estabilizar através da
meditação simplesmente ou do estado
mental que eu simplesmente coloco. Eu
uso ah os órgãos sensuais, os órgãos
sensoriais
para ah ganhar esse foco.
Então, havendo nele desejo sensual, como
é que a pessoa vai ver isso? A pessoa tá
meditando dentro desse espaço livre,
surge algo, a pessoa vê um movimento da
própria energia e vê que esse movimento
convida a outros movimentos.
Então, existe em mim desejo sensual.
Se a pessoa aprofundar nisso, ela vai
encontrar o mundo da forma, vai
encontrar o mundo da não forma. ela vai
encontrar no final a natureza livre da
mente com a luminosidade.
Então, cada uma dessas áreas nós podemos
transformar em caminho, porque nós não
temos nenhuma construção, nenhuma área
que nós estamos olhando que não seja a
manifestação luminosa da própria mente.
Então, o caminho da natural perfeição é
esse. Nós vamos olhando quando essa
meditação se esgota quando nós
reconhecemos o aspecto luminoso e vazio,
não dual de cada uma dessas
experiências, de tal maneira que eu não
preciso nem pensar. Eu ao olhar isso,
né? No início a gente vê: "Uau, surgiu
isso, isso é uma perturbação."
Mais adiante nós o qualquer manifestação
que surja pelos sentidos ou estados
mentais flutuantes, todos eles são
vistos instantaneamente como a
manifestação luminosa
da grande abertura.
E a grande abertura segue como o nosso
refúgio. E nós vemos todas as aparências
que possam surgir como manifestação
dessa grande abertura,
sem precisar nenhum raciocínio e nenhuma
causalidade, sem precisar lembrar de
coisa alguma, porque basta olhar, nós
estamos vendo. E essa experiência que
vai trazer a a
é que é o ensinamento essencial que o
Buda vai dar pro velho senhor ou pra
velha senhora, né? Então é que é um
ensinamento clássico quando as pessoas
dizem: "Não, mas eu não tenho aptidões,
eu não não entendo, eu não tenho visão
filosófica, eu não tenho nem memória, eu
não tenho como praticar.
me deêu uma instrução fácil, simples,
direta, que eu não precise ter que
lembrar de coisas e considerar nada
complicado, porque a minha mente já tá
velha,
né?
E assim o Buda vai dizer isso. Não
precisa para reconhecer o aspecto,
o aspecto
amplo. Tu não precisa memória, não
precisa nada. Aí simplesmente
tá operando desse modo, desse modo
direto que é
todas as aparências, elas já são vistas
como construções ou vistas imediatamente
como construção.
Aquilo é muito simples.
Não tem filosofia ali, não tem análise,
não tem vacuidade ali.
Sabia que você não ia aguentar isso.
Agora eu vou responder ou não? também
tenho.
>> É que realmente, Lama, eh, boa parte da
filosofia contemporânea, esse é um ponto
muito difícil de assimilar, que é a
possibilidade de olhar desde o lugar
nenhum, desde o
>> desde lugar nenhum.
>> É assim que eles chamam o olhar livre de
referenciais, né? Que seria o olhar
livre. é um olhar que não tá situado. É
como se a gente abstraísse então da as
nossas relações socioculturais,
influências biológicas que nos cercam
para realmente olhar como eles chamam
desde o ponto de vista de Deus, né?
seria o olhar que não é afetado.
Então eu realmente me pergunto se é
possível ter certeza de estar olhando
desde um lugar livre ou apenas um pouco
mais livre sem aqueles condicionantes
ã que me permitem ver, por exemplo, a
experiência do medo, a experiência do
desejo. OK, eu olho e apercebo, mas eu
posso ter certeza de que esse olhar que
está realmente vendo isso não tá também
sob a influência de outros
condicionantes pré-reflexivos que estão
estruturando a minha experiência. Eu
posso ter certeza.
>> E aí, Vine? Resolve isso, Vine. Vamos
lá.
Ah, não tem uma experiência técnica,
isso pode ser um ruim
para isso
>> não quer se comprometar.
[Risadas]
Tu podia eh falar em tibetano, ninguém
entende aquilo. Pronto. Aí fica todo
mundo uau. Sim. É isso.
>> Experiência.
>> Essa é uma questão interessante assim,
ou seja, como é que a mente pode ver o
que a mente tá fazendo, né?
Mas é assim,
ah,
o,
se a gente entender que as coisas são
construídas,
se a gente entender que elas são não
doais, fica mais fácil.
Por quê? Porque as coisas, sendo não
doais com a própria mente, elas são
manifestações luminosas.
E quando surge qualquer manifestação
luminosa, quem é que vê a manifestação
luminosa que eu tô criando?
É a própria mente. Eu não posso duvidar
que a mente tá vendo o que eu tô
construindo.
Aí eu digo: "Não, mas a mente tá vendo a
realidade". Não, a mente tá vendo o
poste. E aqui não tem poste.
Ela tá vendo a sala de meditação e aqui
não tem sala de meditação. Então, a
minha mente tá vendo o que ela mesmo
criou.
Então eu não tenho dúvida nenhuma de que
a mente vê a sua criação,
mas ela não é uma mente trouxa que
poderia ser, né? Ela ela vê a sua
criação e vê que ela tá dentro da sua
criação. Ela vê
porque não tem como tu pegar uma
artificialidade
e que a mente cria e fazer ela ficar
obscura pramente pra própria mente que
tá criando.
Aí como é que tu vai fazer? Tu vai
separar isso? Como? Não tem como
separar. Então isso é descrito como
autoconsciência.
Autoconsciência. Por quê? Porque ela já
tá visível, completamente visível. Uma
vez que se eu visse realidades ou não
visse realidades e as realidades fossem
externas, eu posso dizer: "Ah, minha
mente pode ver ou pode não ver". Mas eu
não tô vendo realidades, eu tô vendo
mundos construídos.
Então, eu vou trabalhando esse tema e eu
não não escapa nenhum. Todos é tudo
construído, não dual, luminoso e a e a
grande abertura que produz tudo tá ali
sempre. Você não precisa fazer esforços,
não precisa ligar nem nem desligar, não
tem problema. Aquilo tá lá. E a
construção que surge, ela é vista por
quê? Pela própria mente,
né? Então, por exemplo, se tem alguém
chegando novo aqui, diz: "Olha, aqui é a
sala de meditação".
E a pessoa diz, vocês chamam isso sala
de meditação.
A gente é assim, é uma pessoa que já
veio com a visão, né? Ela diz: "Uau,
isso é nomeado aqui como tal.
É assim, a gente
é assim,
mas essa sala é impermanente, a gente já
vai avisando assim, né?
Mas aí a pessoa se dá conta, a própria
pessoa se dá conta.
é o que temos, ou seja, é como eu crio,
né? Assim, então tem um um fator, eu
acho super bonito o fato de que a sala
de meditação tem um tempo final. Como é
que a gente vê isso? Nós estamos vendo
que tem um um mudrar, que isso aí tem
esse nome, né? Mudrar é um posição que
eu crio.
Essa posição ela sustenta a sala de
meditação até tu desfazer ou mudrar.
e a propriamente sabe que ela fez e que
ela tá sustentando aquilo, né?
E essa autoconsciência, Lama, será que
eu posso ter certeza de que ela também
já não é dotada de interpretantes?
Todo o olhar numa perspectiva eh da
filosofia contemporânea da linguagem,
ele já é dotado também de interpretantes
para que eu possa compreender o que eu
tô vendo. Já tem talvez condicionantes
muito profundos operando ali. Então eu
pergunto se em experiência, em
meditação, mesmo que possa haver uma
sensação de tá olhando desde um lugar
mais amplo e livre, se eu posso ter
certeza de que realmente é livre ou há
um condicionamento operando aqui ainda?
É assim, nós estamos eh
nesse nível, quando nós estamos olhando
isso, eu não preciso de memória, eu não
preciso de palavras.
A experiência base é a simplicidade
absoluta da mente livre.
Então eu não eu não preciso me valer de
palavras em inglês, alemão, espanhol,
sânscrito. Não preciso de palavras,
eu não preciso de conceitos. Por quê?
Porque tem essa experiência. A tua mente
tá flutuando ou a mente tá
estável?
É isso
aí. A pessoa, ela não tá, não tá
perguntando isso para si mesma. Minha
mente tá, a pessoa não precisa dizer
isso. A pessoa sabe quando a mente
flutua ou como a mente não flutua. Então
a base essencial da experiência é essa.
É a mente livre de características e não
dual.
Essa é a base.
Então, esse é o absoluto.
Agora, esse absoluto é construído ou não
é construído? Aí, se os filósofos
quiserem pensar sobre isso, eles podem
pensar como quiserem, né? Mas eles não
vão encontrar linguagem, não vão
encontrar memória, não vão encontrar
outra coisa, não vão encontrar ah idade,
tempo.
Obrigado,
>> hum,
>> tudo começou com o desejo sensual, não
passar.
A me gusta la perspectiva de
[Música]
punto de vista filosicológicos
como construcismo
o construccionismo social son un paso en
direc a una deconstruc
algo de ra forica
un realismo
[Música]
inocente no
la mayor parte de las personas viven en
la realidad pensando que los objetos
existen inherentement
inocente. Claro.
Una teoría de la correspondencia entre
palabra y objeto y las perspectivas
críticas de la filosofía la sociología
muy basadas en el lenguaje son un paso
en dirección a despertar a la ilusorid
de existen los objetos independient del
observador
pero creo que están un poco atrapadas en
el lenguaje, ¿no? dependen del
teorías críticas
y el dharma presentando
una meta visa
allia
sea como la mente construinosamente
incluso antes de linguens
como una oposi entre una filosofia e una
mística pensaria como um contínuo de
deconstrucción de uma realidade
aparentemente sólida na perspectiva.
>> Eu acho que na na verdade nós estamos
entrando numa área super problemática
aqui, porque nós vamos listar tudo que a
mente faz
e nós vamos perceber que aquilo é feito
e não é feito. Ou seja, existe uma
liberdade além da mente. Enquanto que,
de modo geral, nós consideramos que a
mente é o ponto último. E o aqui nós
vamos retirar isso.
>> Porque que nós vamos falar dessa
natureza ampla, que ela também não é
apontada, não é alguma coisa em algum
lugar, ela não é um objeto, mas ela cria
os objetos. E nós vamos descobrir que
tudo aquilo que a gente aponta como
mente
eh inclui aparências e aí inclui
movimentos.
Mas aqui nós estamos falando de de uma
base que não inclui que não tem isso,
que ela tá incessantemente presente, ela
não tem conteúdo que a gente possa
associar a conteúdo de mente e também
não tem movimento.
seenta que objetos crea mente
la mayor parte del tiempo
al menos la mos
crea objetos per luego no lo reconoce
como creo que lo rica
enamora o rechaza
la mayor parte del tempo perdidoso
perdido mas eu diria assim eu vou
defender a mente agora é assim
eu gosto da mente assim essa confusa.
Por quê? Porque ela ela é capaz de
construir realidades, pular para dentro
da realidade e sair surfando no meio
daquilo como se aquilo fosse real, né?
Então ela cria mundos e e vai andar lá
dentro, só que ela esquece. Esse é um
pequeno problema,
>> ela esquece daquilo, né? Mas eu prefiro
olhar a mente como um aspecto lúdico,
>> tá?
>> E não como é que eu acho que, por
exemplo, a pessoa sai para passear, não
tem que ficar olhando pro relógio a hora
de voltar, entende?
É isso aí, Ra criou aquele mundo, agora
hoje nós vamos em tal lugar aí, tudo
bem, vamos esquecer os horários, deixar
o relógio em casa, celular, a gente sai
pelo mundo aí. tá lá. Aí tu diz, não
pera aí,
eu acho que eu esqueci demais. Eu também
já não sei como voltar,
né? Aí tu começa a procurar naquele
mundo construído, não tem porta de saída
do mundo construído,
não tem. Aí tu, ih,
aí tu constrói outro mundo, pensa, não,
daqui é outro. a gente constrói outro e
nós estamos nessa situação.
>> Acho esse olhar mais lúdico, muito
legal. Eu acho assim,
>> mais libertador, mais relaxado,
>> porque ele também permite a gente
sorrir, ó, esse esse mundo assim, aquele
mando ali, até mesmo para sofrimento. A
gente só não pode sorrir muito quando o
outro tá em sofrimento, mas a gente
é assim, porque aquilo é assim, aquele
sofrimento do outro, se eu levar a
sério, eu não tô ajudando ele.
Nós temos que, se a pessoa conseguir o
rir do seu sofrimento,
assim, isso é uma boa coisa assim.
Assim, então aí tem isso até que se
chama liberação pelo riso. Liberação
pelo riso que quebra a estrutura do
sofrimento, quebra a panela dos
infernos. Ela,
né? Tu não, tu não vai assim, essa
panela não existe, essa panela é
delusiva, esse óleo é delusivo, isso
aqui é tudo delusivo, tu dá uma risada,
aquilo quebra assim.
Então, os tibetanos, eles têm várias
histórias desses tipos assim, né? Já no
zem, as histórias que quebram, elas são
um pouco sérias,
pouco dramáticas,
mas também tem essa coisa de quebrar,
né?
Ja.
A gente tem que renovar agora o Fino tá
aqui. A gente tem que renovar as piadas
dharma que quebram, né? Eu agora eu
lembro só lembro as antigas que eu já
contei tudo. Eu não vou contar de novo.
Aí apareceu alguma nova aí.
Mas os tibetansos tem muitas histórias.
Bom aí
diga aí, Vin. Existe em mim desejo
sensual.
[Risadas]
Tu chegou bem nesse ponto.
E aí o umbico compreende, existe.
Isso já é um é quase iluminado. Ou não
havendo nele desejo sensual, ele
compreende, não existe em mim desejo
sensual. Ele também compreende, pá, não
tem.
E ele também compreende como se
despertam os desejos sensuais que ainda
não despertaram. Essa parte ela tá
cortada aqui, não tem nenhuma instrução.
E como acontece o abandono dos desejos
sensuais despertos?
E como acontece para que os desejos
sensuais abandonados não despertem no
futuro, que é o mundo dos monges assim,
né?
Havendo nele uma vontade
e aí surge os outros, né? Havendo
preguiça e torpor, havendo nele
inquietação e ansiedade, havendo nele
dúvida, um um bico compreende. Existe
dúvida em mim. E não havendo dúvida
nele, ele compreende, não existe dúvida
em mim. Então aqui eles estão
percorrendo o universo mental dos
praticantes que estão lá, né? Estão
falando sobre isso. Ele compreende como
se desperta a dúvida, ops, que ainda não
despertou. E como acontece o abandono da
dúvida? Desperta. E como acontece para
que a dúvida abandonada não desperte no
futuro?
Agora vamos ver o que que é isso. Ele tá
chegando a conclusões sobre as coisas?
Não, não tá chegando a conclusão
nenhuma. A prática é se manter
independente de tudo que surge. Nós
estamos só listando as confusões que nos
engancham e nos levam para um lado e pro
outro.
Aí se vi alguém reclamar de você, você
não tá vendo que você tá com raiva?
Digo, não, eu eu tô contemplando a
raiva, eu tô me mantendo independente,
mas se eu não tiver raiva para
contemplar, como é que eu vou
contemplar?
e dá um nó no outro praticante.
É assim,
dessa forma ele permanece contemplando
os objetos mentais com objetos mentais
internamente ou ele permanece
contemplando os objetos mentais com
objetos mentais externamente.
Ou ele permanece contemplando os objetos
mentais com objetos mentais tanto
interna quanto externamente.
Ou então ele permanece contemplando
fenômenos que surgem nos objetos
mentais, ou ele permanece contemplando
fenômenos que desaparecem nos objetos
ambos os fenômenos que surgem, como os
mentais. Aí vocês imaginem assim, o que
que tá aparecendo na tela do cinema ali?
Tá parecendo isso, tá parecendo aquilo,
é isso que nós estamos olhando. E nós
nos mantemos independentes.
É isso.
Eu acho que a gente tinha que ter um
catálogo de filmes de todos os reinos
dentro do mundo desejo, o reino dos
infernos, né? Eu acho que tá um monte de
gente querendo ver filme dos infernos
assim, mas eu acho que também o filme o
filme do mundo da felicidade assim
também os pessoal iam gostar.
Tinha, vai ter sempre um grupo lá que,
bom, mundo dos semideuses, vamos ganhar.
Nós estamos, temos que descobrir como é
que eles fizeram para vencer.
Sim né?
Eu
tô com dó do reino humano atualmente
assim. Acho que o reino humano tá meio
esvaziado.
Por exemplo, reino humano é assim. Eu
queria ter uma casinha com janelas
vermelhas, um jardinzinho junto de um
lago com as árvores, com frutas e uma
hortazinha, os animais.
É tipo assim, eu quero uma casa no
campo, vocês entendem? Esse, eu acho que
isso tá assim, né?
Tá mais ou menos, pessoal. Isso é o
mundo,
é um mundo humano. A gente acredita que
vai ter um parceiro, uma parceira que já
veio de outra vida. A gente tem uma
super conexão, nós vamos ser felizes,
nós vamos envelhecer juntos e vai
demorar para envelhecer. E assim, aquilo
vai ser muito bom. Nós vamos celebrar
bodas de ouro com os netos, bisnetos,
tataranetos,
Natal, todo mundo reunido
assim, todo passando as receitas de
bolo, receita de de das várias coisas.
Aquilo é que era mundo, pessoal. Assim,
agora jogo a carta, jogar um
futebolzinho, as crianças jogando
futebolzinho na frente.
Pense, alguém brincando de cavalo, né?
Andando a cavalo e uns poneis, né, para
as crianças andarem.
O os cachorros correndo para cá,
correndo para lá e os gatos também.
volta mei mas é tudo amigo
assim pessoal os ratinhos da casa de vez
em quando
é assim já sabe que eles estão ali.
O rei não manda é assim, uma felicidade
é na parede as fotos dos ancestrais,
né?
Assim,
mas quando apareceu o celular,
[Risadas]
aí
o reino humano começou a entrar em
decadência.
Grupo de WhatsApp, os grupos de de
WhatsApp acabaram com
a namorada ver o que que anda rolando
nos grupos de zap, aquilo não dá certo.
Eu não tô olhando para ti, viu?
>> Ou então
ele permanece contemplando os fenômenos
que surgem nos objetos mentais ou ele
permanece contemplando fenômenos que
desaparecem nos objetos mentais ou ele
permanece contemplando ambos os
fenômenos que surgem como os fenômenos
que desaparecem nos objetos mentais.
Ou então a atenção plena de que existem
objetos mentais
se se estabelece
somente na medida necessária para o
conhecimento
e para a continuidade da atenção plena.
A gente não tem, não bota realidade
naquilo. E ele permanece independente,
sem nenhum apego a qualquer coisa
mundana. Assim é como um bico permanece
contemplando objetos mentais como
objetos mentais. Ele permanece
independente. Nós vamos até o fim,
pessoal. É isso. Sempre a prática ele se
mantém independente. Dependente
significa o quê? Ele tem a confiança na
visão daquilo, ele vê aquilo surgindo,
ele não se vincula
também, não se opõe.
Ele tá, ele tá gerando clareza com
relação às aparências. Essas aparências
são dharmas. Aquilo tá virando dmas e
assim estão surgindo os protetores do
dharma.
Aí vem os cinco agregados que a gente
gosta de trabalhar isso, né?
Novamente, bicos. Um bico permanece
contemplando os objetos mentais como
objetos mentais referentes aos cinco
agregados influenciados pelo apego e
como um bico permanece contemplando os
objetos mentais como objetos mentais
referentes aos cinco agregados
influenciados pelo apego. Aqui um bico
compreende. Assim é. Então é forma,
sensação, percepção, formação mental e
conscienso.
Assim é a forma material.
Esta é a sua origem. Esta é a sua
sensação.
Essa frasezinha, pessoal,
tem um bocado de coisa para tu fazer,
né? Eu olhando as múltiplas formas, aí
tem os elementos que aparece
a experiência de que aquilo é sólido,
né? É o templo. Nós estamos cheio de
exemplos da forma, né?
Então essa é a sua origem. A gente
também pode dizer: "Bom, quando eu tô
sonhando,
eu sonho com uma casa,
essa casa é forma,
mesmo sendo um sonho, né?
Aí nós vamos dizer sim, ela é forma,
porque forma é tudo que tu aponta como
se fosse separado de ti. Mas não é
incrível. Aí tu tá sonhando, não tem
nada no sonho que não seja a própria
mente operando, mas ela produz uma
aparência e produz a visão que vê a
aparência na forma da da sensação de ser
alguém.
Então, a gente se veste de conteúdos
e quando olha as formas que a gente
cria, a gente vê casas.
Então, a forma material, quando diz
material, inclui nos sonhos também.
Essa é a sua origem, essa é a sua
sensação.
Assim é a sensação. Essa é a sua origem.
Essa é sua sensação. Assim a percepção.
Essa é a sua origem. Essa é a sua
sensação.
Assim são as formações voletivas. Essa é
sua origem. Essa é sua sensação.
Assim é a consciência. Essa é a sua
origem. Essa é a sua sensação.
Então, a consciência aqui a gente já
olhou desse modo, né? A consciência é o
aspecto luminoso que faz com que as
luzes surjam como objetos.
Aí tem nos ensinamentos, nos
ensinamentos da natural perfeição, tem
as seis luzes.
As luzes não são luzes, elas são luzes
sutis.
Então, quais são as luzes que me
permitem ver coisas a partir das luzes,
né?
Sim. Então, nós estamos penetrando
dentro disso. Agora, a gente poderia
pensar, b, que complicação, ten que
fazer tudo isso
muito complicado.
Então, por que que a gente entra nisso?
As pessoas vão dizer: "Bom, eu entrando
nisso, isso aqui é super analítico, isso
aqui é filosófico, complexo, difícil.
Hum.
Mas isso não é
desse modo difícil filosófico,
que exige essa memória e etc, né?
Naturalmente, se vocês quiserem
memorizar o texto, vocês vão precisar de
memória.
Mas aqui a memória do texto não é o
ponto. Aqui o ponto é nós, vocês podem
simplesmente pegar o texto e percorrer
isso como quem percorre
estados mentais.
Então, o texto ele surge como um
influenciador
de Aí nós vamos entrando nas regiões que
produzem significados para nós, aonde
tem regiões cármicas, onde tem nós
entramos em a lei virginana, né, que é a
mente onde tem os depósitos cármicos.
E nós começamos a olhar
as coisas a partir de grupos de
significados.
Aí, se eu olhar segundo esses
significados, aquilo aparece desse
jeito. Se eu olhar de outro, aparece de
outro jeito. Se eu olhar de outro,
aparece de outro jeito. Então, eu vejo
que eu tô dentro dessas regiões
e isso tá acontecendo. Mas por que que
eu vou fazer isso?
Eu vou fazer isso por quê? Porque aquilo
que aparece diante de mim, ah, tá me
enganando. Eu olho para aquilo e aí eu
sou arrastado para dentro de bolhas e
começo a operar dentro de bolhas e não
sei como sair.
Então eu tenho que usar o próprio
conteúdo das bolhas para sair. Então
quando eu olhar bem dentro da bolha eu
saio. Que é mais ou menos assim. Por
exemplo, nós estamos vendo um filme, eu
tô sofrendo no meio do filme, eu não
consigo sair do filme. Então eu vou
mergulhar dentro do filme e vou sair do
filme por dentro do filme.
Aí eu começo a olhar, n que a luz
chegando, aquilo tá batendo para cá. Aí
eu começo a olhar a realidade daquilo
mesmo. Aí eu saio.
Por quê? Porque não tem realidade ali.
Assim é esse esse aspecto todo, né?
Então, por isso que esses essas questões
aqui elas parecem elas parecem muito eh
detalhadas,
mas eh esse detalhe todo aqui eu não
preciso seguir, eu posso simplesmente
eh,
por exemplo, no Zen não tem essa
descrição toda, mas em princípio eu tô
operando com qualquer experiência que
surja. Então, o Zazeném é a experiência
de iluminação diante de qualquer
aparência.
Tudo bem?
Mas quem pratica assim,
depois de um tempo,
a pessoa provavelmente vai
aspirar
a a conexão não apenas com a linhagem
sotô, mas com a linhagem rinzai. Por
quê? Porque a linhagem rinzai vai trazer
os coãs. A linhagem Soto não tem os
coãs.
O coan é a própria aparência onde ela
tá. Mas como a gente desenvolve uma
familiaridade,
então nós podemos começar a achar que as
aparências elas são naturais.
Aí nós não conseguimos fazer prática.
Então eu preciso do da linhagem Rzai,
que vai me trazer
vai me trazer questões paradoxais.
Então, essas questões paradoxais, elas
quebram a forma usual de operar.
Então, elas me convidam a olhar de uma
forma mais profunda e me tiram o
conforto diante das aparências, né?
Então esse é o ponto. Aí tu precisa
disso. Isso vem por quê? Porque a pessoa
praticando assim, ela vai
olhando, ela termina gerando uma visão.
Essa visão é condicionada. A pessoa tem
a sensação de que ela é condicionada.
Por quê? Porque de tanto em tanto ela
ultrapassa a visão que ela tinha
desenvolvido duas semanas, um mês, um
ano antes. E aquilo dá uma sensação
muito desagradável.
Por quê? Porque nós somos bicos sérios.
Ou seja, eu não quero me enganar a mim
mesmo.
Não quero ficar criando alguma coisa que
depois eu descobro que eu engano. Pá,
não tenho tempo para perder.
É assim, a vida é curta e nós também
estamos aqui fazendo esforço, a gente
quer resolver.
Então, surge nos praticantes uma
aspiração
intensa
de
eh de uma condição aonde ah os nossos
obstáculos não são amortecidos, mas eles
são evidenciados
e eles surgem nítidos na nossa mente.
Nós temos que ultrapassar aquilo. Então,
a gente aspira isso.
Então, eventualmente a gente aspira que
o mestre seja esse veículo.
Aí, de modo geral, nós estamos aspirando
ensinamentos irados e não ensinamentos
pacificadores.Éé,
Então, durante um longo tempo, nós temos
uma aspiração de ensinamentos
pacificadores,
porque nós temos sofrimentos aqui,
sofrimentos ali, a gente quer resolver
aquilo, mas tem um momento que a gente
aspira alguma coisa disruptiva, porque
sem alguma coisa disruptiva fico um
pouco calma assim, só para ver de
repente parece umaharaja e me atropela e
explode tudo sem eu ver de onde é que
ele surgiu.
Asim.
Então, o Gil, eu não vou nem falar, o
Gil ficou aqui um longo templo, aí
surgiu não sei bem o quê e de repente o
Gil foi embora.
Vamos deixar assim, né?
pela internet, surgiu Mara no Nordeste.
Mara veio aqui direitinho de saia e
levou ele.
É assim, ele nunca mais conseguiu
voltar,
viu, Vini? Foi isso que aconteceu
assim. E aí?
Sim,
eu não vou falar mais nada.
E aí foi assim,
assim que a gente perdeu o Vinim.
Mas aí tu fica olhando assim: "Uau, e
agora?"
né? Aí tu não sabe
por quê? Porque eh tá acomodado numa
sensação de segurança.
Portanto, nós precisamos de
um empurrãozinho do Buda,
dizendo: "Você já olhou aquele canto
lá?" É tipo a mãe diz: "Agora vocês
arrumem a sala".
Aí nós lá tchau tchau. Tá pronto mamãe.
Mamãe, vocês foram lá atrás da coisa
viram? Varreram lá. Não, não, não varrei
agora. Tá pronto. A mãe disse: "Vocês
tiraram o pó dos móveis?" "Não, não
tiramos. Então vamos tirar o pó dos
móveis". E vocês varreram aqui, varreram
ali, tiraram isso, botaram para lá e
agora penduraram a vassoura e fizeram
isso. Sim. Então tá assim. Aí o Buda tá
dizendo, vocês olharam cinco agregados,
é isso. Olharam forma, olharam sensação,
percepção, formação, bolitivo e
consciência.
Aí nós, pá, esqueci isso. Abençoado.
Então, que que vocês estão esperando?
Quando aparecer a forma aqui do reino
dos deuses, que que vocês vão fazer?
Vocês vão embarcar direto.
Nosso pai abençoado. Obrigado aí.
É isso aí. Tem, aparentemente é uma
complicação. Tu vai dizer limpar uma
casa é uma complicação,
né? Por quê? Porque assim, tem que
varrer o teto, melhor fazer na ordem,
não? Varre o teto, varre as paredes,
tira uma por uma das aranhas com
cuidado, bota o lado de fora, vai
citando maniper maniper,
né? É assim.
e vai tirando as traças
e vai limpando as coisas todas, né? É
assim. Aí tu vai descrevendo o que que é
uma limpeza. Aquilo é uma coisa
gigantesca. Aqui nós estamos tratando da
limpeza, pessoal, porque a instrução
e a pessoa faz aquilo tudo, ela se
mantém
livre,
né? Esse é o ponto. Todos esses aspectos
que aparecem, eles são perturbações.
Como é que a gente sabe que são
perturbações? Cada uma dessas
aparências,
ela nos engancha e nós começamos a andar
para cá e para lá.
Então, dessa forma, ele permanece
contemplando os objetos mentais como
objetos mentais internamente,
externamente,
tanto interna quanto externamente. E ele
permanece independente, sem nenhum apego
a qualquer coisa mundana. Esse é o
ponto.
Então, eu acho isso muito, essa
expressão aqui muito importante,
pessoal. permanece independente.
Não é assim, ele atingeu iluminação.
Aí tu tem, aquilo é complicado porque tu
vai ter que explicar, então aquilo é um
estado mental, não é o estado mental o
que que é. Então aqui o Buda tá
descrevendo toda a variedade de
aparências que podem surgir. Ele
classifica e aí ele se mantém
independente, lúcido. Ele não engancha.
E quando ele entra e se move ali dentro,
ele também não engancha. Ele continua
livre.
Assim é como um bico permanece
contemplando os objetos mentais como
objetos mentais em termos dos cinco
agregados do apego. Eu diria que aqui é
uma etapa da descrição, vai ter visão,
meditação. Nós estamos numa etapa de
meditação. A gente não tá propriamente
em a emção. A gente até pode estar em
ação, mas a gente precisaria então não
tá sentado, tá andando em volta.
Aí as múltiplas experiências aparecem e
a gente se livra. Mas aqui o Buda tá nos
dando um empurrãozinho. É como se a
gente sentado em chama a gente se
acomodasse. Agora a gente começa a ver a
dança dos demônios, interferências
fantasmagóricas, espíritos despeitados e
malévolos. Todos eles são manifestações
da mente.
E aí surgem as seis bases.
Novamente, bicos. Um bico permanece
contemplando objetos mentais como
objetos mentais referentes às seis bases
internas e externas.
Por exemplo, como é que seria o engano
com respeito à prática? é vocês listarem
tudo isso
com uma descrição que o Buda faz sobre a
mente, começarem a comparar isso com
outras coisas e etc. Nós estamos
perdendo tempo, pessoal. O que o Buda tá
falando aqui não é isso. O Buda tá
falando sobre o fato de nós estarmos
sermos independentes de qualquer
aparência.
Ou seja, ele tá andando em direção à
simplicidade, não a complexidade de
descrições.
Ele tá pegando essa complexidade para
reduzir a simplicidade que a nós vemos
isso, isso surge, cessa, isso surge
luminosamente, é não doal com a nossa
mente e nós nos mantemos independente. É
como se a gente tivesse trabalhando essa
parte, né? Eu começo com chamata. Depois
eu vejo demônios, interferências,
fantasma, maggica, espíritos respeitados
e malvos, que estão todos escritos aqui.
E aí eu vejo a mente livre de
características.
E aí eu tomo vacuidade e luminosidade
como doredrolo, como a essência da
lucidez que penetra qualquer construção.
Eu acho que isso dialoga com os
filósofos, sabe? Eu acho que os
filósofos aspiram Dorge and Drolo, eles
ficam meio desconfiados de Dorge Drolo,
mas é assim,
se a gente, se o filósofo perguntar o
que que é a minha mente desconfiada, ele
descobre que aquilo é doredro.
Porque essa mente que não quer se
submeter a nenhuma construção,
ela desconfia de todas as construções.
Mas para escapar disso, ela tem que
descobrir que a desconfiança também é
uma construção.
Eu diz lá para eles lá.
Novamente bicos. Um bico permanece
contemplando os objetos mentais com
objetos mentais referentes à seis bases
internas e externas.
Como um bico permanece contemplando os
objetos mentais como objetos mentais
referentes às seis bases internas e
externas.
Aqui um bico compreende o olho, ele
compreende as formas e ele compreende o
grilhão que surge na dependência de
ambos.
Então aqui nós vamos ver essa
consciência, essa ligação
que é a consciência luminosa que com que
conecta a a sensação de existência de
formas com o próprio olho, né?
Então ele também compreende como surge o
grilhão que ainda não surgiu, como se
abandona o grilhão que já surgiu e como
o grilhão abandonado não surgirá no
futuro. Então aqui, se eu tiver a
consciência construindo diretamente das
luzes, eu tenho grilhão.
Mas por vezes nós vamos perceber que as
luzes vêm como, por exemplo, o cubo,
aquele desenho, né? Aí as luzes vem, mas
eu não consigo ver o cubo.
Aí eu vejo, ele não surgiu. Aí como que
a gente abandona o grilhão que já
surgiu? E como o grilhão abandonado não
surgirá no futuro enquanto delusão, né?
Aí ele compreende o ouvido,
compreende os sons, compreende o olfato,
os aromas, compreende a língua,
compreende os sabores, compreende o
corpo e todos os tangíveis.
Os tangíveis, pessoal, inclui movimentos
de todo tipo por dentro do corpo. Tudo
aquilo que a gente puder localizar,
isso tá dentro do corpo. E ele
compreende a mente, ele compreende os
objetos mentais, ele compreende o
grilhão que surge na dependência de
ambos. Ou seja, a gente cria imagens. As
imagens parece que são nós mesmos. nós
começamos a produzir originação
dependente e ficamos presos aquilo.
[Música]
Ele também compreende como o grilhão que
ainda não surgiu,
como surge o grilhão que não surgiu,
como se abandona o grilhão que já surgiu
e como o grilhão abandonado não surgirá
no futuro enquanto delusão, né? Dessa
forma ele permanece contemplando os
objetos mentais como objetos mentais.
Então ele tá listando esses objetos
mentais.
Então internamente, externamente, tanto
interna quanto externamente. E ele
permanece independente. Esse é o ponto.
Sem nenhum apego a qualquer coisa
mundana. Assim é como um bico permanece
contemplando os objetos mentais como
objetos mentais referentes à seis bases
internas e externas.
E aí surge os sete fatores da
iluminação.
E então esse ponto eh esses dois pontos
agora que a sete fatores da iluminação e
as quatro nobres verdades,
eles concluem o sutra, né? Então nós
vamos olhar isso um pouco adiante.
Eu acho muito interessante isso, porque
especialmente
os os sete fatores da iluminação,
eles eles parecem fatores da iluminação,
mas o Buda vai eh vai ah nos convidar a
que a gente se mantenha independente.
Acho isso super precioso, pessoal.
Você
pode tá
os sete fatores da iluminação
aqui ele surge como objetos mentais.
Eles estão na classificação, né? Porque
eu tenho a mente e os objetos mentais.
Entre os objetos mentais, o que que eu
tenho?
as características da iluminação.
Ou seja, o Buda, ele não acredita na
iluminação.
Eles são objetos mentais que
surgecessam, são construídos.
Então, quando o Buda descreve isso, ele,
na verdade, ele tá dando a transmissão
da lucidez, a transmissão de de guru
yoga, da sabedoria primordial, da
confiança na natureza. livre da mente.
Ele tá dizendo, não se fixe, não
estabilize nada, não crie estados
mentais se fixe.
Mas isso a gente vai ver ah adiante, né?
Eu não sei como é que vai ser hoje,
assim, como é que tá a situação, né?
Vou mandar normal, né?
Então, amanhã de manhã a gente ainda tem
um tempinho para concluir aqui e mais
algumas coisas, mas eu diria assim que a
gente não precisa ficar
preocupado, né? Por quê? Porque essa
prática ela independe do próprio
Satipatama.
O Buda tava oferecendo esses esses
demônios aqui pra gente olhar,
porque eles têm uma afinidade com os
praticantes, esses demônios todos aqui.
A gente se conecta, né? Eu acho isso tão
interessante. Por exemplo, quando vocês
vão olhar o sutra surangama,
então o surangama ele vai não crescendo,
ele começa com aqueles probleminhas do
Ananda, aquilo vai indo até que tá tudo
claro. Aí quando tá tudo claro, surge os
múltiplos bodáfos. Tem uma assembleia de
bodáfas, todo mundo contando como é que
viu, como é que não viu. Aquilo é 1
terço do sutra. ter mais um tantão.
Aí o o o
Ananda pergunta: "Mas como é que a gente
faz para isso,
para atingir isso, né? Aí como é que
então a gente medita? Aí vem vindo
instruções que seriam como que
preliminares,
né? Lá no na parte mais final.
Ah o
a pergunta é
quais são os obstáculos?
Aí o Buda vai descrever os demônios.
A gente pensa, pá, eu não queria o final
do sutra é demônio agora.
Eu queria afinal iluminação,
né? Mas iluminação ele conta na primeira
parte. Aí nós entramos na parte dos
demônios. E os demônios são o quê?
Os demônios são isso aqui.
É isso aí. Ele vai lançar algumas,
como é que eu vou dizer? Não vou, não é
maldição, é uma bendição, né? Mas aquilo
tem uma cara de maldição.
Por quê? Porque ele vai dizer, se você
tomar aquilo e os demônios surgem como
se fossem
seres de grande sabedoria, de grande
lucidez. Então vocês peguem assim os
sete fatores da iluminação.
Aí são sete sábios, todos vestidos de
branco, com com emanando luzes
e vão tentar prender vocês em alguma
coisa
construída.
Então esses são os demônios. Então ele
vai apontando os demônios como as
construções aparentemente dignas da
mente, né? Ele vai começar com demônios
do tipo, eles vão lhe dizer que você
pode matar, eles vão dizer que você pode
roubar, você pode cometer ações sexuais
como forem, você pode mentir, pode se
intoxicar.
Aí ele vai começar assim, né? Aí tem os
demônios mais densos, aí tem os outros
demônios mais sutilis,
mas são sempre estados mentais que a
gente coloca e que considera que é
digno né?
Esse é um ponto bem delicado, porque ah,
por exemplo, dentro da visão do próprio
Buda, o Buda tá relacionando
um conjunto de obstáculos que ele tá
trazendo para nos ajudar.
Mas lá aquilo é apresentado como
demônios. Então a gente vai precisar
entender que aqueles demônios a gente
não
resolve
lutando contra eles. A gente resolve
iluminando eles
assim.
Vamos parar nesse ponto aqui.
Que os méritos desse encontro se
expandam e toquem a todos. Que o Mestre
Universal da Paz e da Compaixão, Sua
Santidade da Lailama, juntamente com
todos os mestres de todas as tradições
que veiculam essa mensagem, tenho longa
vida. que todos estejam a salvo de gerar
pensamentos negativos, os mais
destrutivo, que esses pensamentos nunca
surgem em nossa mente e que todos os
seres também estejam livres de
pensamentos negativos
ao longo de minhas muitas vidas e até
este momento, todas as virtudes que t
alcançado,
inclusive os méritos gerados por esta
prática e todas as que vier a conseguir,
ofereço para o bem-estar dos seres
sencientes.
Possam a doença, guerra, fome e
sofrimento diminuir para todos os seres,
enquanto sua sabedoria e compaixão
aumentam nesta em vidas futuras. possa
eu claramente perceber todas as
experiências como sendo tão
insubstanciais quanto tecido do sonho
durante a noite e imediatamente
despertar para perceber a manifestação
de sabedoria pura no surgir de cada
fenômeno. possa eu rapidamente alcançar
iluminação para trabalhar sem cessar
pela liberação de todos os seres budas e
bodissátuas em conjunto, seja qual for a
sua motivação, sua ação benéfica e
preces auspiciosas,
seja qual for a sua onisciência,
realizações e poderes benévolos. E seja
qual for a sua imensa sabedoria,
eu, que igualmente venho para beneficiar
os seres, rogo para que possa alcançar
as mesmas qualidades. Neste exato
momento, possam nem mesmo os nomes
doença, fome, guerra e sofrimento ser
ouvidos pelas pessoas e nações da terra,
mas possam sim sua conduta moral,
mérito, riqueza e prosperidade crescer.
E posso suprema bem-aventurante
[Música]
Pode falar, João.
>> Boa tarde, La, boa tarde a todos. É
rapidinho, Lama. Eh, ontem à noite,
quando eu tinha perguntado se eu tinha
falado de estudar o surta, meditar o
sulta ele, né? E hoje, agora o senhor
falou que mais importante do que a
memorização era manter o aspecto livre
da mente. Eh, eu entendi que de repente
aquela parte de corpo era bom seguir o
roteirinho para poder perceber toda a
formação
>> e agora essa parte da mente de formação
mental, a gente trabalhar com o conteúdo
que cada um tem. Seria mais ou menos por
aí? Eu acho que pode ser assim, mas
também pode aproveitar o que tá no
texto. Tu não precisa memorizar o texto.
Seria isso, né? Nem considerar isso como
se fosse a única forma de contemplar os
obstáculos, mas tu pode usar essa
listagem, ou seja, acessar de novo o
texto e dizer: "Bom, agora vou praticar
essa parte com esses elementos, né? Isso
seria uma boa forma".
>> Obrigado.
>> Tá bom, querido. Um abraço aí. Pode
falar Guta.
>> Bom dia, Lama.
>> Bom dia.
>> Obrigada pelos. João já era boa tarde.
Hoje que ele já tinha almoçado, mas para
nós aqui é
>> Lamar, a minha pergunta é mais de afução
no mundo, mais relacionada a uma coisa
que o senhor falou hoje. Ã, eu tenho
conversado com a minha irmã porque ela,
tá muito triste com o falecimento do pai
e da mãe. Ela tá vivendo luto bem
difícil assim.
E aí, eh, tem tentado, né, ajudá-la a
ampliar a visão. Mas hoje, quando o
senhor falou sobre asques, eu tava pens
me ocorreu uma coisa que de repente eh
as experiências eh disruptivas, assim
como
o falecimento de alguém, pode ser visto
como uma daquim e aí nos levar paraa
liberação.
ou pode ser visto como uma rara,
que aí nos a gente vê como uma coisa
ruim que aconteceu e que nos aprisiona
no sofrimento. Será que esse tipo de
visão, o que que você acha desse tipo de
visão L?
>> A gente pode transformar qualquer
experiência numa experiência de
liberação, né? A pessoa consegue, é uma
boa coisa.
Se não consegue, a gente tenta
pacificar, tenta melhorar, tenta levar a
pessoa para uma outra base, para uma
outra bolha, né? Mais favorável,
uma terra pura, o lugar mais favorável,
mas a pessoa pode olhar diretamente, né?
Mas e aí dá para nomear a quando surge
como liberação, dá para nomear como
possibilidade de liberação dá para
nomear como da crime e quando a pessoa
fica aprisionada assim no sofrimento, dá
para liberar, dá para nomear como
sendoará?
>> Eu acho que dá, mas eu não sei se essa
questão ajuda muito, sabe? Porque de
modo geral daquine surge um ser
aqui é uma morte, né?
Então eu também não sei se é muito útil,
porque o nome a não produz a liberação,
né?
Mas se eu disser que as circunstâncias
do mundo elas se transformam, são
dharmas e eu eu clarificando as
circunstâncias do mundo, eu vou me
liberando da delusão. Então isso é uma
boa coisa. O Boda ensina isso também. Eu
não preciso converter pra palavra
daquineia ou pro sentido de daquinia,
né?
>> Tá certo, Lava? Muito obrigada.
>> Bom, Gat, um beijo aí.
>> Obrigada.
Tchau, pessoal. Até depois. Beijo
grande.
Tchau, Lama. Gratidão.
>> Tchau. Gratidão.
>> Tchau.
>> Obrigado. L.
Bom dia, Sanga.